you
toyota has given the Yaris a face lift
the front in particular has been
revamped giving the car a more striking
modern appearance the project management
for the new look was headquartered in
France to set itself apart from the
crowd the car maker has given the Yaris
a hybrid drive
and Zach new breed Toyota's product
manager for the eris as it was offered
as a hybrid for the first time in 2012
back then Toyota anticipated that a
quarter of the irises ordered would be
hybrids but the hybrid success
astonished the company forty percent of
the current generation of the RS is sold
our hybrids the company expects the man
to keep growing to forty-eight percent
in the mid term and in the long term
more than fifty percent of all your
asses will be delivered as hybrids with
a skinny fat foot so Toyota has set
ambitious goals we wanted to see if the
Yaris hybrid could convince us
automotive bloggers larissa would kofsky
got behind the wheel for us
yes I'm Larissa's first impression of
the irises interior is good there is a
lot of plastic but in this segment in
price class that's inevitable she knows
that one of the materials is unfamiliar
to her it doesn't seem quite modern but
she says even if you don't like it it's
not obtrusive a license canceled more
down hours of a shot of him full of
machinery phase manish mark the yaris
starts at the push of a button the
battery is charged so we leave the fuel
pump without filling up and off we go
that's five fifty credits her car
Chester notes how smoothly and simply
the yaris drives everything works
without the driver having to think too
much about it a plus the car shifts from
the electric to the gasoline engine
quickly and almost unnoticeably another
plus the only hitch is that the engine
takes a moment to respond but Larissa
says that's a very minor problem she's
satisfied with how the car works I
started off kind of fighting Tina Fey on
the school's net ID super the new yaris
is just under four meters long and 1.7
meters wide compact dimensions for city
traffic and parking Canada Hackman
racism flats in money ERISA says that
the car feels roomy enough even though
its dimensions are compact and practical
you have enough space to feel at ease
and free to move she thinks it's a bit
of a shame that the c-pillar is so large
that can be disturbing when you go into
reverse to park or when you cast a
glance over your shoulder to judge the
traffic book that's iron parked but I
heard of mine was on Showtime they can
start by camera animals otherwise the
view was good she says and the car ends
almost with the rear windshield so the
c-pillar should make parking a big
problem they can he saw horse get on
the yaris hybrid we tested has 74
kilowatts of power and consumption is
rated at 3.3 liters per 100 kilometers
it launches from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in 11.8 seconds and has a top speed
of 165 kilometres an hour
hinda unstated stepped behind her car
Chester is a Toyota Yaris hybrid with
all the optional features its price is
twenty one thousand euros Larissa says
she'd consider a lower priced version
with a little less comfort and luxury
but that's a personal decision she
advises anyone who wants to drive a
hybrid car to consider the toyota yaris
my uncle
thus car tester montas kirat looks at
the new mercedes vito and another new
Vito and yet another new veto veto on
insta diamond corporation offers more
than 1,000 different ways to put
together your own personalized midsize
vans I'm not says Amon stand quinta it's
a taxi the car maker demonstrated this
versatility when it premiered the white
van in an old power station in Berlin
it's a careers van or a company bus
the rear-wheel drive version with a
strong engine can carry heavy loads
while the eight seat version could
shuttle a full volleyball team the veto
is the only vehicle in its segment to
offer a choice of front rear or
all-wheel drive
Ben dekhoon get some Pokemon in Vega
mercedes-benz explains that a heavy-duty
vehicle up to 3.2 tons total weight puts
a heavy load on the rear axle looking
and trailer to it puts even more weight
on the rear axle so this clearly
requires a rear wheel drive but for a
lower total weight vehicle even at
maximum load there's much to recommend a
front-wheel drive if you only ever drive
around town then of course front wheel
drive is definitely the proper choice
this one done given it absolutely still
odd the veto came onto the market with
two engine options both Diesel's a 1.6
liter with a 65 or 84 kilowatts of power
for front-wheel drive and a 2.1 litre
diesel with 3 power ratings for rear and
all-wheel drive a few changes have also
been made to the interior compared with
a predecessor model
I'm not my second autofilter Mornhinweg
points out that great attention was
given to optimal economic design for the
driver that is the sitting position the
position of the steering wheel the
pedals Mercedes has reworked everything
the bowhead for instance was designed so
taller people can lean about eight
centimeters farther back and be more
comfortable riding in the van theme I
sarma boot and fought like five and cudi
album and there are three stowage spaces
over the instrument cluster that are
partially covered to minimize
reflections from the windscreen doin
Donovan chat I Paquette now the front is
a bit steeper to offer better protection
for pedestrians the cargo space posts
and intelligence seating rail and
locking systems the headlights are
available in halogen or LED lights with
taillights to match the rear can be
accessed through either a hatchback
tailgate or twin doors now Mercedes is
offering two sliding doors for the veto
montes sums up saying the 3dr concepts
front wheel rear wheel and all will make
for lots of versatility and a lower
price tag fuel consumption has been
improved with 5.7 liters being the best
rating for this series and currently the
best in the entire class but as soon as
the competitors bring out their latest
models all bets are off and Mercedes
developers will have to step on the gas
emissions damn missing dish problems is
not to lease out and incumbent on yahoo
in cycling brain-o unveils the new
twingo built on the same platform as the
smart forfour that's why the Twingo now
also has a rear engine and rear wheel
drive the three cylinder engine with a
start/stop system uses four point two
liters per 100 kilometers the new
version offers more interior space than
its predecessor from two doors the new
twingo has moved to for the little
French car will be seen on German roads
starting in September the basic model
costs 9500 9000 less than its
predecessor
fiat has made its van the Fremont more
versatile at least and looks the Fremont
cross is designed to appeal to SUV
buyers featured are not only front and
rear spoilers in the cross design but
also 19-inch wheels leather appointments
and a touch screen gps device of course
the Fremont cross can be ordered with
the already familiar electronically
engaged all-wheel drive vigholf it often
[ __ ] if you want to drive an opal with
the top down says cards history Manuel
Shaffer your only choice is the cascata
it shares its floor assembly with the a
string and that's about all the rest was
either developed specifically for the
cascada or borrowed from the insignia so
let's see how the cascata performs by
the states in the line as soon as he
turns the ignition key the seat build
holder moves forward making it much
easier to grasp the bill Dennis
authority fight him opal sees the
cascada as a member of the premium class
at four point seven meters it's exactly
as long as a Mercedes e-class
convertible I mention I copy when you've
got a convertible well then you can put
the top down scissor car gesture that
can be done in the cascata at speeds up
to 50 km/h that takes about 15 seconds
the roof motor is specially encapsulated
to reduce the noise it makes you can
hardly hear it
ask me I mean the manual says he doesn't
like the great number of instrument
buttons you have to look carefully to
find the one you're looking for and that
distracts your attention from the
traffic he also thinks the USB input an
auxiliary output like a bit makeshift
but otherwise the interior looks very
good fresh and sporting like the whole
car and he thinks everything goes well
together in England estas con he also
likes the cascada steering a good
compromise not too tight not too soft
the steering wheel itself fits well in
the driver's hand but Amon wall doesn't
much like how it looks the cascada
convertible comes in three gasoline and
two diesel engine versions we're testing
the 1.6 liter gasoline powered model the
manufacturer says the car needs six
point seven liters of fuel for 100
kilometers but if your driving style is
sporty it's more like nine liters the
new engine has 147 kilowatts and
accelerates the cascata from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and nine point two
seconds top speed is 235 kilometers an
hour
enough adolphe comic art mr. notes the
choice of driving mode tour or sport
tour is for relaxed cruising for example
on long distances on the highway or you
push the sport button red illumination
appears behind the instrument panel so
you know you're in sport mode now the
fuel uptake is more direct and the
driving is more fun amana likes the
cascata sassiness it accelerates well
and takes curves dynamically and
stabling as a gasoline-powered car it
takes a while to hit its stride but once
it's rpms are up then it really moves
the cascada also has a lot to offer in
the way of safety systems optional are a
front camera with traffic sign
recognition a lane departure assistant
and a distance and collision alert
to conclude when it's a card sister
wants to mention two things first all
you have to do to open the trunk is
press on the Opel logo there's no handle
and that looks better but the trunk
offers little room to blame is the space
needed for the retracted roof and the
trunks opening is small as well the
trunk could hold two crates of beverages
hardly more but amanda was still
convinced after all this is a
convertible not a freight transporter
and he can't resist going for another
spin Kalyan can last nazar on this
operations of no wonder each year in
July tens of thousands of motorcycle
fans converge on garmisch-partenkirchen
for the BMW motorrad days where they
talk shop and party through the weekend
the unofficial star of this year's event
was 81 year old sub vente and is over 60
years on the road he's collected 23 two
wheelers
he's been a motorcycle enthusiast since
his youth he got his driver's license in
1950 and drove a 200cc German Victoria
in 1953 he bought a new habla and in
1954 a 500 CC BMW his favorite is the
r50 he says the engine runs like a dream
and has a much better pickup than the
250 CC engines it's entirely different
and lots of fun on the road ok Danny
roars up nothing frail about this old
man all eyes are on Seth and his are 50
as they take their place at the head of
the pack right behind the police escort
sep seems to enjoy being the center of
attention this is his 15 minutes of fame
motorcycle riders have to know what
they're doing to live as long as sep
eric a motorbike instructor explains
what to do if your machine unexpectedly
tips over you don't see where you go ok
and after you
difficult and I can leave the back with
one leg because I don't go
forward one day it is do this
my leg since my booty
the motorcycle fans came from all over
Europe many of them are veteran bikers
with thousands of kilometers behind them
the biker and his bike might stay
together for decades BMW itself can
boast of over 90 years of rich and
successful motorcycling history in the
1920s BMW sports model r37 collected
honors on the racetrack including three
class victories in its first time around
BMW made the 16 horsepower are 37
available to private buyers in 1925 the
racing cycles kept getting lower and
lower BMWs boxer engine was ideally
suited to this design seen here on the
1972 rs500 BMW won the Iowa man tourist
trophy nine times and the german
championship six times BMW won the
paris-dakar rally again and again
through the 1980s and in 1998 made a new
start with this single cylinder model
based on the f650 Beemer scored its
biggest success in the year 2000 taking
both first and fourth places in the
Dakar Rally rookie writers can lose
their training wheels on this 2010 BMW
s1000rr fim superstock it puts out 142
kilowatts at some thirteen thousand rpms
riders must be under 24 years old
the motor odd days even have something
for absolute beginner bikers like milena
art and a closed-off space she can
sample the feel of the open road even
without a motorcycle license pitch
Gonzalez can see me cooking demodulation
I wish Ben story well you know it's
never driven a motorcycle before she
wants to see if she can do it she gets a
few pointers and she's off on her first
lap even if driving instructor godfried
Medicus keeps his hand on the machine as
a safety precaution letting milena
concentrate on learning to ride
now she can feel the power she's sitting
on and knows better than to
underestimated she's a bit stressed but
still having fun for her or anyone who's
never done it it takes quite a lot of
getting used to here to a little courage
and self confidence will go a long way
in just a few minutes milena has godfre
jogging along beside her yuck it makes
her feel happy she says it's like a
dream she can imagine that driving a
motorcycle properly would be incredible
she wouldn't mind giving it a try ashlyn
he slashed tougher
with a stunt show Monty Griffin of
Ireland takes the spectators breath away
sitting standing on two wheels or one
he's perfected the art of motorcycle
riding
vons from the netherlands BMW motorcycle
club sums up the whole event and a few
words BMW motorcycles have a model for
everyone he says it's great fantastic
poor in dutch while indicas are qld not
many vintage car buffs would head there
darlings into a lake unless it's a VW
type 166 amphibious vehicle where other
cars reached the end of the road this VW
is right in its element
the still and well navigable waters of
the Rhine mind Danube canal and the
various picturesque odd muta are ideal
for taking a dip with an amphibious car
once a float the car's engine has to be
switched off and the propeller let down
and you've got a motor boat ready for a
leisurely cruise the 24 and a half
horsepower engine drives the door Lascar
at speeds up to 10 kilometers per hour
or about five and a half knots
owners of the type 166 often like to
test its limits on land and water both
driving it through water is as easy as
falling off a log long time type 166
owner Godfrey's mo explains all you have
to do is steer and step on the gas it
has no rudder and uses the front wheels
to steer with a little practice you can
make tight turns on the water come on of
course of God Rogers come on then
but a driver's license is not all you
need to be able to take the amphibious
car into the water godfred says he can
only go where boats who are allowed not
on any other body of water and he needs
a boat master's license to show he knows
the rules of the waterways and their
traffic science lots of eiganjo
stateside media for hillside you know
it's a vital
once the type 166 leaves the water the
propeller is disengaged from the drive
shaft and tipped up as soon as the
driver puts the vehicle in gear the
engine re-engages the wheels
as one sexy curvy body designer pitler
explains that the entire body is
waterproof and when the propeller is
tilted down into the water and locks
into a dog clutch it generates forward
drive in an example I'm dived won't
assume it did for three it's like the
size because the passenger uses the
special lowering rod to put the
propeller down where it automatically
engages the drive shaft it's evil it's
powered by the simple air-cooled VW
engine that was installed in the first
VW beetles
the type 166 is technology is based on
vw's original strength through joy car
developed by Ferdinand Porsche but it
was designed for use by the German van
mocked in World War two Porsche was more
interested in the technological
challenge than the war effort and came
up with a floating body with four-wheel
drive comfort was not high on the list
of priorities about 14,000 type 1 66 s
were built today only about 160 road and
seaworthy specimens have survived
with most parts interchangeable with
early vw's it's not difficult to restore
a type 166 even if the parts can no
longer be found on the open market VW
may be persuaded to remanufacture it so
these vintage cars can be kept shipshape
for a long time to come the longer
they're kept in shape the higher the
prices rise even if a collector can be
found who's willing to part with a type
1 66 in good seagoing condition it will
likely be for a six-figure sum even a
junker commands a high price
the VW type 1 66 is the supercar among
four-wheel-drive classics on land and
water its unique strength was its
off-road capability
how many other vintage are classic cars
can you drive into a lake just for the
sheer fun of it and bring it back out
again